I don't want to be the skunk at the
picnic so to speak raping your mother up
golden beaver beaver and suck now I'm
going to force you at gunpoint to eat me
alive sex with Satan sex with Satan in
the wake of last December school
shooting senator Jay Rockefeller has
proposed yet another congressional study
on violent video games such studies are
typically accompanied by hearings where
representatives of the world's greatest
deliberative body get to lecture and
threaten artists and businesspeople in
front of national TV cameras that would
normally not pay much interest to the
Senate Commerce Committee
Madonna's effect a book that I haven't
seen but I read report of it violent and
perverse television shows shows like
foxes when animals attacked
mr. Snyder and what does SMF stand for
it stands for the sick [ __ ]
Friends of Twisted Sister is this also a
Christian group I don't believe that
profanity has anything to do with
Christianity blaming pop culture for
America's societal ills has been a
staple of congressional hearings for
decades where the First Amendment is
usually regarded as an archaic nuisance
and I still hear art is art and in
America artists are supposed to be free
to express themselves and every time
somebody said all you can't that's
censorship oh you can't do that that's a
violation
First Amendment parental responsibility
is considered an impossible task the
television has truly become our
electronic babysitter and everything
from serial killers Son of Sam killed
eight people in New York was allegedly
into black sabbath's music to suicide he
hung himself while listening to a CDC's
shoot to thrill to deviant sex panties
round your knees with your ass and
debris have been blamed on artists whose
work seems rather silly and campy with
just a few years of hindsight I think
somebody should sponsor a sleaze Awards
where people show up not in black ties
but in coveralls dressed as garbage men
on occasion devil's advocates have been
invited to testify on free expressions
behalf though they're commonly met with
snide insults from lawmakers who bristle
at the mere mention of the word
censorship often we've heard that a
record never killed anyone or we're
casually dismissed as proof
sir sensors as Congress gears up for
another round of scaremongering
grandstanding recent TV presents sex
violence and Satan six unbelievably dumb
congressional hearings from 2001 the
House Committee on Energy and Commerce
is hearing on children and media
violence their parents in America who
think some of this music is killing
their children softly raping your mother
killing your mother get me the machete
from OJ I'm gonna make everyone's throat
sake it was horrifying I hope it does
not take another Columbine or another 13
year old shooting a teacher or another
eight-year-old shooting a classmate I'm
watching the Popeye with my young son
Bluto punches out all the windows in a
rage and then my own son ran out to the
glass storm window and punched his way
through it in 1997 Senator Joe Lieberman
and the Senate Committee on governmental
affairs spent a lot of time talking
about Marilyn Manson some of the worst
thoughts shoot here in the world gets
smaller shoot shoot shoot [ __ ]
I'd say that the lyrics to this song
contributed directly to my son's death
and I fail to recognize that my son was
holding a hand grenade and it was live
and that it was gonna go off in his mind
I understand how you feel but don't be
don't be too hard on yourself
almost every parent in America in that
position would have done exactly what
you did because it didn't look like a
hand grenade it looked like a CD
unfortunately it wasn't him grenade I
know you don't agree with this but when
you look at a painting what makes one
painting good and one painting bad it's
a matter of taste
I don't hear in your testimony any real
acknowledgement about how terrible this
music is when you hear the testimony of
mr. Koontz doesn't it make you want to
go back Marilyn Manson to petrichor
Cannibal Corpse loop doggy dog to me
this music is the equivalent of yelling
fire in a crowded theater where there's
no flair also in 1997 the Senate
Commerce Committee held hearings on the
ineffectiveness of the TV rating system
they themselves had imposed on the
industry their sometimes that I wish
that I could wave a wand or pass a law
that would
get this junk off of television it may
be that you have to just have a proceed
of each show written printed in the
papers and in the digest and people can
actually read what's in the show go to
head
yeah I need everyone to know what a
lying [ __ ] Donnie is I remember coming
home one night when one of my boys have
been sitting with a babysitter watching
a television program it scared him
because of the violence that came across
that TV screen and he couldn't sleep
that entire night don't remain in denial
don't force us to legislate again in
this area most of the programs are
falling in the PG category is because
many of them are very bland four years
ago the Congress indicated the network's
that they wanted the primetime schedule
with less violence in it and I think the
network took responding of course bottom
line mr. president mr. chairman I have
such high regard for you in 1993 Joe
Lieberman in the Senate Committee on
governmental affairs took on the scourge
of ultra-realistic 16-bit video games
and plastic toys I know that one place
parents want us to draw the line is with
violence and video games game last year
it's called the super scope the gun that
you have in your hand is called the
justifier to me that looks like it looks
like an assault weapon of some kind also
in 1993 Attorney General Janet Reno
responded to fan mail I received these
letters from 75 children attending Park
Elementary School dear Miss Reno I don't
like violence on TV it makes me feel
rotten
I know Murder She Wrote that's not
fortuitous violence I mean it murder
itself some of it could be you've shown
a day at party and that's acceptable and
tell me whether you think this is good
nobody died except the credibility of
the panel it's gonna be important to the
maintenance of constitutional freedoms
in our country unless people
self-regulate is going to lead to
genuine threats to our freedom of code
and bball Biba and something else they
they had I haven't seen it I don't watch
it but whatever it is that walls at 7:00
o'clock bus code and they put it on now
at 10:30 I think they've pleaded guilty
and they'll do it as long as you and I
have here we just don't have hearings
like we've had now for 40 years and
going all the way back to 1985 when
Senator Al Gore's wife tipper along with
Treasury secretary James Baker's wife
Susan founded the parents music Research
Council and used their husband's bully
pulpit to hold hearings on the dangers
of quote/unquote porn rock much has
changed since Elvis seemingly innocent
time rock lyrics have turned from I
can't get no satisfaction so I'm going
to force you at gunpoint to eat me alive
young people in our treatment program
recovering from drug problems we asked
them to give up heavy metal for at least
a year so that they're not again
overtaken by feelings of resentment hate
and the urge to party repeated exposure
to song lyrics describing rape incest
drug taking and flirtations with the
occult i fu ck like a bee is like
sandpaper to the soul the question we
must ask is should the force be the
government clean up your act or we will
do it for you in the words of the heavy
metal band Twisted Sister we're not
going to take it anymore
bang your head against the stage like
you never have before make it ring make
it bleed make it really sore burn the
building burn burn burn he will possess
you
he will molest you sex with Satan sex
with Satan it's my life and I love sex
Prince's darling Nikki about
masturbation I met a girl named Nikki I
guess you could say she was a sex fiend
I met her in a hotel lobby masturbating
with magazines in a cardinal sin baby
Let Me In girl I'm gonna treat you right
well goodness sakes my snakes alive and
it's ready to bite listen you little
[ __ ] do as you are told
come with Daddy for me to pour the
golden showers all through my excrements
you shall roam bend up and smell my anal
vapor your face is my toilet paper on
your face I leave a [ __ ] tower golden
showers thank you sorry your time has
expired
the complete list of PMRC demands reads
like an instruction manual for some
sinister kind of toilet training program
whipped up like an instant pudding by
the wives of Big Brother people who
write bad laws are in my opinion more
dangerous than songwriters who celebrate
sexuality some of the album's that have
been selected for abuse here are
obscurest I think that a lot of deep
digging was done in order to come up
with the song about the anal vapors do
you make a profit from sales of rock
records yes thank you I think that
statement tells the story to this minute
the beauty of literature poetry and
music is that they leave room for the
audience to put its own imagination
experiences and dreams into the words
there is no authority who has the right
or the necessary insight to make these
judgments today's young people viewing
musicians that to all outward
appearances would offend their parents
are intelligent and sophisticated enough
to play such performers in their proper
context and to make their own judgments
and in fact many of these musicians are
viewed as little more than glorified
comic book characters really to
underestimate the ability of young
people today to make these perceptions
just begins to expose the problems that
ante regulatory steps would create see
what toys your kids ever had why would
you be interested point of interest in
this house I'll show them to you